I had a decent amount of successful and
she and I met and then I lost everything
I didn't just lose everything once I
actually lost everything twice the
absolute rock bottom of that whole
period of time I actually told her I
thought she should leave me I respect
her I cared about I was like we're cool
if you leave I respect you I was trying
to sell her on leaving me and she
grabbed my chin and she pulled it
towards me and she was like I would
sleep with you under a bridge if it came
to that in some ways like she sold me on
me I'm just the guy she met on the
internet who lost everything and now
we're crashing at her parents house I
think our marriage is rarer than our
business success I'm very grateful for
that